Most of Game of Thrones happens in Westeros
– home to the Starks and Lannisters, the
Wall and the Iron Throne. But Daenerys’
story starts in the eastern continent of Essos
– with the Dothraki Sea, and Slaver’s
Bay. We also see Braavos, Pentos, Volantis,
Valyria in the show, and Qarth. But the world
of Game of Thrones is far bigger than we see
in the series. The worldbook describes far
distant cities and kingdoms, with their own
cultures, histories, and mysteries. Some of
the strangest places are in the far east of
Essos, and in the southern continent of Sothoryos.
Sothoryos is full of jungle, ruined cities,
and mystery. No one knows how big it is. A
dragonrider once spent three years flying
over the continent, but she never found its
southern border – said it’s “a land
without end” . Colonies on Sothoryos have
all failed , and treasure-hunters don’t
return . Cause the jungles are full of disease
– blood boils, sweetrot, wormbone, Red Death
. Archmaester Ebrose says that disease kills
half of all Westerosi visitors . And those
who survive the sickness are often killed
by the wildlife. There are “Huge crocodiles”,
“carnivorous fish”, snakes, and basilisks,
and apes so huge they can kill elephants with
one punch . The only animal that isn’t deadly
is the purple-eyed lemur, called the Little
Valyrian . Further south, in the Green Hell
regions, are said to be vampire bats that
can drain a man of blood, and tattooed lizards
with claws on their legs , like some kinda
dinosaurs. “Most terrible of all are the
wyverns”, which are similar to dragons.
They don’t breathe fire, but they’re angrier
to make up for it . Some kinds hunt in packs
of a hundred , or use stealthy black scales
to sneak crit their prey . And if somehow
you survive the wildlife and the disease,
there are slavers prowling the coast . And
there are the native Sothoryi, called Brindled
Men. They’re hairy, big-boned, “massively
muscled” “creatures”, with noses like
snouts, and thick skin like a hog, coloured
white and brown – Brindled Men can’t reproduce
with other humans . The Brindled Men near
the coast have learned to speak the local
“trade talk”. But the Men further south
are said to be “savage” cannibals, who
worship dark gods . It’s said there were
once lizard men, and eyeless cave-dwellers
– old races who were destroyed or devoured
by the Brindled Men . But the greatest mystery
of Sothoryos is Yeen. Yeen is a ruined city,
“older than time” and built from massive
blocks of “oily black stone”. No trees
or vines touch it – it’s “A city so
evil that even the jungle will not enter”
. When Princess Nymeria tried to settle some
Rhoynar in Yeen, the entire population “vanished
overnight” .
So that’s Sothoryos. Off its western coast
are the Basilisk Isles – “the festering
sore of the Summer Sea”. Hot and humid,
the Isles swarm “with stinging flies, sand
fleas, and bloodworms” . Old Valyria used
an isle as a penal colony for their “worst
criminals”. In their city of Gogossos, Valyrian
“torturers devised new torments”, and
practiced “blood sorcery”, mating “beasts”
“to slave women” to birth “twisted half-human
children” . It’s actually crazy how often
“half-human children” are mentioned in
the books . It’s possible that ancient inter-species
breeding is what gives Targaryens their dragon
magic, and the Starks their warging powers.
It’s also possible that some of these twisted
monsters on Sothoryos might have been created
by Valyrian blood magic. There’s some weird
shit in the books. Anyway, after the Doom,
Gogossos grew “rich and powerful” on slavery
and sorcery , until it was wiped out in a
plague . Eventually, people returned – and
the Isles are now home to pirates, in towns
with names like “Sty”, “Whore’s Gash”
and “Black Pudding” . They have charming
local customs, like piling the skulls of their
enemies on an island “as an offering to
some dark god” . Occasionally, the Free
Cities come to wipe out the pirates, but the
pirates always come back. One time, a captain
called Saathos Saan was sent to destroy the
pirates, and instead he became a pirate king
who ruled for thirty years . Saathos Saan
is an ancestor of Davos’ friend Salladhor
Saan. Also, in Book 5, Barristan Selmy trains
a boy from the Basilisk Isles, called Tumco
Lho – and Barristan says he’s “the best
natural swordsman” he’d seen “since
Jaime Lannister” , which is high praise.
One of the Basilisk Isles features an “ancient
idol” of a “gigantic toad” of “malignant
aspect”. The statue is forty feet high,
and carved of “greasy black stone”. The
people of Toad Isle have “an unpleasant
fishlike aspect to their faces, and many have
webbed hands and feet” . So like Yeen, this
is a reference to H. P. Lovecraft, who wrote
about strange fishy people worshipping strange
fishy gods. These “black stone” structures
are scattered all over the world of Thrones,
and it’s hinted that they were built by
a Lovecraftian fish people called the “Deep
Ones” – whose descendants apparently still
live on the Toad Isle. So in conclusion, the
worldbook says, the Basilisk Isles are “best
avoided” .
Thousands of years ago, in the grasslands
of Essos, the first civilisations began . Legend
says that a Silver Sea was ruled by Fisher
Queens from a floating palace . There were
savage Hairy Men who rode to battle on unicorns
, and a city of Lyber where “acolytes of
a spider goddess” warred against those of
“a serpent god” . It’s said there was
a kingdom of centaurs – who might have actually
been “mounted warriors” . These are just
ancient legends, but we do know there was
a kingdom called Sarnor. The Sarnori called
themselves Tall Men, and they were “Warriors,
sorcerers, and scholars” . They built cities
across the grasslands, with canals, caravans
and libraries, worshipping a “hundred gods”
. Sarnori soldiers “wore steel and spider
silk”, and rode “scythed chariots” , with
women and men fighting together . Sarnor warred
against the Qaathi, and the Dothraki, and
even fought in Valyria’s wars against Ghis
. The Sarnori were divided into lots of rival
kingdoms, but traditionally they were ruled
by a High King in a wondrous Palace With a
Thousand Rooms . Legend says that the first
High King was called Huzhor Amai, which sounds
like Azor Ahai, the hero who ended the Long
Night . Many of the cultures of Essos have
their own versions of that story – it’s
like how Noah’s ark and the Epic of Gilgamesh
tell different versions of the same flood
myth . Sarnor dominated the west grasslands
for thousands of years . But after the Doom
of Valyria, the Dothraki united, and attacked
Sarnor in force. City after city fell, and
Sarnor was too slow and divided to fight the
threat . They were broken in a final battle
called the Field of Crows. Now, their kingdom
lies in ruins, and fewer than twenty thousand
Tall Men remain .
North of Essos is a vast ocean called the
Shivering Sea. It’s full of fish, crabs,
seals , whales, and leviathans the size of
islands . Sailors also describe mermaids,
and “drowned spirits”, and mists that
can instantly freeze a whole ship. There are
many reports of ice dragons, “colossal beasts”
much bigger than regular dragons. They’re
made of living ice , and breathe cold instead
of flame – which might explain the freezing
mists. When ice dragons die, they melt, so
no one can prove they exist . In the far north
is an arctic waste where the blizzards never
end. Sailors describe strange lights in the
sky, which might be aurora borealis. They
are also tales of Cannibal Bay, where ships
enter, then are trapped when the sea freezes
behind them . It’s said that “a thousand
ships lie entombed in Cannibal Bay”, “still
inhabited by the children and grandchildren
of their original crews”, “who survive
by feasting [on] the flesh of sailors newly
caught” . Much of the Shivering Sea is ruled
by the people of the island of Ib .
The Ibbenese are short, strong , and hairy
, with ridged brows and massive jaws . Ibbenese
can sometimes reproduce with other humans,
but the offspring are sterile . So like the
Brindled Men, the Ibbenese might be another
species of human – kinda like how Neanderthals
lived alongside homo sapiens in the real world
for a while. The Ibbenese are cunning craftsmen,
hunters and warriors who fish the Shivering
Sea. Their whaling ships are renowned for
their strength in weathering storms, and taking
whales for bone, blubber and oil. The island
of Ib has of dark forests and mountains, full
of bears, wolves, and mammoths. Many Ibbenese
live alone in these woods as foresters or
miners. But others live in the main Port of
Ibben, in the shadow of the God-King’s castle,
a “colossal” ruin that once housed “a
hundred Ibbenese kings” . Under the God-Kings,
Ib conquered the forests to the south, which
were inhabited by “a small, shy forest folk”
called the Ifequevron, or woods walkers. The
woods walkers are thought to be related to
the children of the forest of Westeros – the
woods walkers “carved trees”, like how
the children carve weirwoods. But the woods
walkers also built a “settlement” or “City”
, which is cool, cause we’ve never seen
a city built by the children in Westeros.
The God-Kings are gone now, and Ib’s ruled
by a council of nobles. But the woods walkers
are said to still live in the deeper woods,
and will bless a household that leaves offerings
of leaf and stone.
East of Ib, we start getting into the really
distant lands. Author George Martin warns
us that we’re seeing this world from the
perspective of Westerosi maesters, whose information
on distant places might be inaccurate. Distortions
and errors creep in – ‘here be dragons’
type stuff. So everything from here on in
might be mixed with myth. East of Ib are said
to be the Thousand Islands, a scatter of bleak
windswept rocks. They’re inhabited by a
strange hairless people with green skin and
teeth filed to sharp points. They’re said
to sacrifice sailors to fish-headed gods , but
they’re so afraid of the sea that they won’t
touch the water, “even under threat of death”.
Some say the Thousand Islands are “the last
remnants of a drowned kingdom whose towns
and towers were submerged” thousands of
years ago . So again, this stuff is straight
outta Lovecraft. South of the Thousand Islands
is the port city of Nefer, surrounded by cliffs,
and shrouded in fog. Nefer looks like a small
town, but most of the city is hidden underground
– so Nefer is called “the Secret City”,
known for necromancy and torture . East of
Nefer are the “grim, grey” forests of
Mossovy , a “dark land of shapechangers
and demon hunters” . These mysterious lands
are as far east as any Westerosi has been
.
Essos is divided by a great mountain range
called the Bones, named for the remains of
those who try to cross them . The mountains
are riddled with rivers, canyons, vast underground
caverns and sunless seas . There are passes
into the mountains – “ancient carved steps”
and “hidden … passages” . But only a
few roads lead out of the Bones – the Steel
Road, the Stone Road and the Sand Road . Each
of these are guarded by a fortress city – Kayakayanaya,
Samyriana and Bayasabhad. These cities were
once outposts of the “kingdom of Hyrkoon”.
But the lakes and rivers of Hyrkoon dried
up, reducing the kingdom to ruin . Now, only
these three cities remain, defended by warrior
women who believe that only “those who give
birth” are “permitted to take life”
. The woman “wear iron rings in their nipples
and rubies in their cheeks”, and are trained
in combat from childhood. Most men in these
cities are gelded, and live as eunuchs – only
the strongest and handsomest men are allowed
to breed, and to rule the cities , making
the Bones a confusing mix of matriarchy and
patriarchy.
East of the Bones are the plains of the Jogos
Nhai. These guys are a bit like Dothraki – nomadic
mounted warriors roaming across grasslands
. But the Jogos Nhai don’t ride horses – they
ride zorses, which in the real world are hybrids
of zebras and horses . The zorses of Game
of Thrones are similar, but tend to be tough
and angry . There’s a book character called
Vargo Hoat who rides a zorse in Westeros – he
leads the Brave Companions who cut off Jaime
Lannister’s hand in Book 3. But the Jogos
Nhai are short and squat, with pointed skulls
because they bind their heads when young – which
is actually a thing in the real world . Groups
of Jogos Nhai are ruled by a war chief and
a moonsinger. Usually the chiefs are men,
and the moonsingers women, but sometimes they
switch roles, and live as the other gender
. Because of their religion, the Jogos Nhai
don’t kill other Jogos Nhai. But they constantly
wage war on the peoples around them – including
the cities of the Bones. It’s said that
the Jogos Nhai wiped out the last of the “stone
giants” , who were “twice as large as
the giants of Westeros” , which’d make’m
like 24 feet or seven metres tall. The Jogos
also fight Yi Ti – an empire to the south
. Sick of being raided, the YiTish have tried
to wipe out the Jogos Nhai, and one time they
got close, under Emperor Lo Bu. But a Jogos
warrior woman called Zhea rose up and destroyed
Lo Bu’s armies, claiming the Emperor’s
skull as “her drinking cup” .
Yi Ti is “the oldest and greatest of the
eastern civilizations” – inspired by imperial
China . A land of hills and plains, jungles
and rainforests , it’s said to be so wealthy
that its princes live in houses of solid gold
. Its forests are dense, and said to be infested
with basilisks , but a web of stone roads
provides safe passage . The cities of Yi Ti
more magnificent than anywhere in Westeros
– the current emperor lives in a palace
that’s larger than the entire city of King’s
Landing . So Yi Ti is crazy powerful, and
legend says that thousands of years ago, it
was even greater. The “Great Empire of the
Dawn” covered most of far east Essos, with
riches and armies even greater than the Valyrian
empire . The first emperor of Yi Ti was believed
to be a god on earth – son of the Lion of
Night and the Maiden-Made-of-Light. It’s
said that this first god-emperor ruled for
ten thousand years of peace, until he ascended
to the stars. Yi Ti was then ruled by the
Pearl Emperor, then the Jade, Tourmaline,
Onyx, Topaz, and Opal Emperors, each reign
more troubled than the last. Until the Amethyst
Empress was killed and usurped by her brother,
the Bloodstone Emperor. He began a reign of
terror, practicing necromancy, slavery, cannibalism
and torture. He “took a tiger-woman for
his bride”, and worshipped “a black stone
that had fallen from the sky” – which
might connect to the black stone on Yeen and
Toad Isle.
It’s said that the Bloodstone Emperor caused
the Long Night, when the world went dark and
demons attacked. Yi Tish believe that the
Long Night was ended by the hero Azor Ahai
. So this seems to be the same story as the
Long Night in Westeros, when white walkers
first attacked and were defeated by the last
hero. Yi Ti even has a structure like the
Wall – the huge Five Forts protect Yi Ti
from the “demons” of a “freezing desert”
. So did white walkers attack Yi Ti? Also,
the story of the Bloodstone Emperor is really
similar to the Westerosi story of the Night’s
King. They both marry a monstrous woman, make
themselves rulers, and worship dark forces
. These seem to be different cultures’ myths
of the same events. So what really happened?
What caused the Long Night? And what ended
it? These questions are central to the last
season of Thrones – and the war to prevent
a second Long Night. Another mystery is that
the Five Forts are made of “fused black
stone”. Different to the Lovecraftian oily
black stone, fused stone was made by Valyrians
with dragonflame . But the Five Forts predate
Valyria . So maybe the Great Empire of Yi
Ti had dragons of their own. And another place
with ancient fused stone is the Hightower,
in Westeros. Did ancient YiTish dragonriders
build the pyramids, I mean the Hightower?
We’ll go down that rabbithole in another
video. But check out LuciferMeansLightbringer
on YouTube who goes real deep on this stuff.
South of Yi Ti is the island of Leng. Its
lush jungles are full of tigers and apes , and
it’s rich in “spices and gemstones”
. The people of Leng are some of the tallest
in the world, many reaching seven feet tall
– and they have better eyesight than other
humans . For most of its history, Leng was
“an isle of mystery”, closed off to the
outside world. The Empress of Leng “was
known to have congress with the Old Ones”
– gods who lived in ruined cities deep beneath
Leng’s jungles . Sometimes, the Old Ones
told the Empress to execute all the strangers
on the island . That stopped when Yi Ti invaded
Leng, and became the dominant people. The
ruined cities of the Old Ones were sealed
off. But “Legends persist that the Old Ones
still live” in the darkness below. So these
Old Ones are another clear reference to Lovecraft.
In fact, Leng is the name of a mysterious
interdimensional plateau in the Lovecraft
mythos . Further to the east, there’s also
the city of Carcosa, ruled by a yellow emperor,
and K’Dath, “where unspeakable rites are
performed” for “mad gods” . Author George
Martin has said that he added these Lovecraft
references basically just to fill out the
map – along with places like the City of
the Winged Men, Cities of the Bloodless Men,
and Bonetown. So these places are fun worldbuilding,
but probably not important to the story. There
is one city, though, that seems central to
the world of ice and fire.
Asshai is “Easternmost and southernmost”
– “the end of the known world” . It’s
a huge city – bigger than King’s Landing,
Oldtown, Volantis and Qarth combined . And
Asshai is built entirely of Lovecraftian “greasy”
“black stone”, making Asshai dark and
gloomy even in summer . Though the city is
huge, the population is small. There are no
crowds or noisy markets – people walk “masked”
and “veiled” and alone . There are no
children in Asshai , and no animals. Apparently,
they can’t survive the foul pollution of
the river Ash . The wider area’s called
the Shadow Lands, where glowing ghost grass
grows , and “dragons [stir]”. Asshai is
a centre of dark magic, where red priests,
bloodmages, necromancers, and night-walkers
practice their terrible spells in the night”
. Apparently, magic is stronger in Asshai
, and seekers come from all over the world
to learn secrets and magic. Melisandre, Quaithe,
Marwyn and Mirri Maz Duur all study magic
in Asshai. Euron Greyjoy claims to have come
and “and seen wonders and terrors beyond
imagining” . The masked “shadowbinders”,
like Melisandre and Quaithe, are said to be
the “Most sinister of all the sorcerers
of Asshai”. “They alone dare to go”
up the Ash deep into the Shadow Lands , where
there’s “demons and dragons and worse”.
In “the heart of darkness” lies “Stygai”,
“the City of the Night” , where even “shadowbinders
fear to tread” . So this place seems like
a cosmic centre of dark magic in the world.
The “heart of darkness” is like an opposite
pole to “the heart of winter” in the north
of Westeros . But who built Asshai ? And why
build a giant city out of “oily black stone”?
One theory is that the Bloodstone Emperor
built it – cause he worshipped black stone,
after all. Or maybe, Asshai used to be normal
stone, but some magical cataclysm like the
Long Night transformed it – the polluted
Shadowlands are like the fallout of some disaster,
like the Doom of Valyria. Or maybe Asshai
was built by the Lovecraftian Deep Ones – along
with the cities beneath Leng, and Yeen and
the toad stone. All these evil places seem
interconnected – the darkness of Asshai
runs deep.
So the world of Game of Thrones is far bigger
than Westeros. It’s full of exotic creatures,
ancient peoples, uncomfortable race undertones,
Lovecraftian horrors, and cosmic mysteries.
And these same forces of ice and fire are
playing out in the final season of Thrones.
Much of the artwork in this video is from
Unseen Westeros, an exhibition of work by
forty Game of Thrones artists. You can see
the exhibition for free in Berlin in January.
Or you can get a beautiful artbook on their
Kickstarter. It’s got 80 pieces from Westeros
and beyond, many never-before-seen. This is
all non-profit, this isn’t sponsored, just
a celebration of the world of Thrones and
of the artists who bring it to life. The Kickstarter
is the only way to get the book, and it closes
literally like today, so get it while you
can.
The map in this video is by Klaradox, and
other artwork’s by drafturgy, Mandy Finke,
Sanrixian, Kevin Catalan, Oriana Wiesner,
Matt Olson, and more. Links are below. Most
of the info from this video is from the World
of Ice and Fire, you can pick that up on Amazon
to support Alt Shift X at no extra cost to
you. Thank you for watching. Please like and
subscribe, and thanks to the Patrons, including
Curtis Trotter, Simon Kern, Vijay Ganesh,
and LVE. Cheers.